can we really multiply using our fingers
and toes how about we try multiples of
nine what's nine multiplied by eight
let's number the fingers in a clockwise
direction one two five and six to ten
this is the eighth finger we color it as
we finding the eighth multiple of nine
to get the answer all we need to do is
count the numbers to the left of the
colored finger and the numbers to it's
right
there are seven fingers on the left so
we write a seven first and then there
are two on its right so we write it 2 9
times 8 is 72 color the finger number of
fingers on its left and number of
fingers on its right now I want you to
try 9 times 4 I give you 3 seconds okay
as it's the fourth multiple we color the
fourth finger three fingers on the left
so we write a three and six fingers on
the right so we write a 6 9 times 4 is
36 but what if we have a double digit
multiple of nine something like 9 times
12 if it's a double digit multiple like
this you will need to use your feet then
so we use our two hands and our two feet
we number our fingers from one to ten
and our toes from 11 to 20 now we have
been asked to find the product of nine
and 11 we have been asked for the 11th
multiple of nine if the multiple is
two-digit we have to look at the
position preceding it and the position
itself so as we have been asked for the
11th multiple we look at the 10th and
the 11th position one preceding it and
the position itself this is the tenth
position and this is the 11th one and
now we count the positions on the left
and the positions on the right we can
see that there are nine fingers on the
left so we write a nine first and then
there are nine toes on the right
we write a nine again that's our number
nine times 11 is 99 remember if it's a
two-digit multiple then we look at the
position preceding it and the position
itself and then count the positions on
the left and the right now I want you to
try multiplying 9 with 16 I give you 5
seconds as it's the sixteenth multiple
we have to find we look at the 15th and
the 16th position this is the 15th
position and this is the 16th one how
many on the left and how many on the
right 14 on the left so we write a 14
and 4 on the right so we write a 4 9
times 16 is 144 more than a quick way of
multiplying it was more of a fun way
interesting wasn't it